I have on good authority they're doing a
super sexy GQ fashion shoot and I know
they want me there so I can't wait
although they haven't formally extended
an offer I'm sure it's out there it's
pending but you know I'm just going to
surprise them eliminate the paperwork
and show up
myself
[Music]
you must be out of your mind to keep
cing around
[Music]
here you know you're out of the day
Death Around in
[Music]
mind you must be out of your mind to
keep calling this
number I he stab in the dance floor or
here comes the
Thunder social like death
squad
social I death
squad social I death squad
yeah oh this professional model thing is
so exhausting oh man all day I've had
like two cucumber slices and green tea
but my poses are fresh all right you can
take that to the bank the fresh Bank
check out my
app
too much is pass between us for us to be
[Music]
strangers don't you wish we could go
back but here comes the
danger